les tracteurs ont investi versailles ce
mercredi matin une cinquantaine
d'agriculteurs venus de houdan menthe et
rambouillet venus protester contre
l'augmentation programmée des taxes sur
les produits phytosanitaires en france
des pesticides visant à protéger les
plantes des parasites qu'il faut
absolument que l'agriculture française
et les mêmes règles cox et autres
concurrents européens
on a le droit de mettre les mêmes
produits phytosanitaires vous protéger
nos cultures pour avoir les poneys les
mêmes normes et pas de règlementation
française qui viennent serait empilées
on est en train de courir un 100 m avec
un boulet au pied par rapport aux autres
pays producteurs européens
une délégation d'agriculteurs a été
reçue pendant près d'une demi-heure par
le préfet des yvelines jean jacques brot
d'entretien été jugé satisfaisant par
les manifestants je pense que il a une
bonne une bonne approche
je sais pas s'il a beaucoup de pouvoir
et s'il va pouvoir nous aider dans nos
revendications mais ils nous montraient
une certaine solidarité avec ce qu'on
pouvait avancer une nouvelle action
devrait être mené en début de semaine
prochaine dans les yvelines le mode
opératoire n'a pas encore été dévoilé